foreign
asymmetry like this where one side gains
people over time right you've got two
sides that are claiming some something
is inevitable that's another prediction
then right there right so you know I
I said the level of certainty has
changed on one side and not on the other
and and the second prediction here that
you are making is one of the sides is
um gaining people on the other side the
prediction is is going to be losing them
yep so and we know they are because
people have actually gotten vaccine
injured for instance how many people do
you know who
um started out thinking these so-called
vaccines were dangerous and now think
they're safe right that's that's that's
the first yeah like if it doesn't it's
not a known category for a reason and
it's because the evidence is I mean
there were people like like the doctor I
referred to who was like why don't do
this like you had to wait a little bit
and I was like okay
I'm not I'm now going to take it okay
well but then that goes to the point
that you and I were disagreeing on which
is the difference between safety and
harm yep right that's right and so I
would only use a different analogy than
I've used in the past you know uh is it
safe to get in your car drunk and drive
home
no does that mean you're going to crash
nope you could get home absolutely
unscathed right so the point is harm and
safety are two different things we
understand the difference very easily
yeah and no and I and and you're right
that it's important like you to say that
you weren't harmed doesn't mean that it
was safe like this and I I feel like
that's a formulation that I immediately
grok and that I think almost everyone
would too you can say just because just
because I wasn't harmed doesn't mean it
was a safe thing to do whereas looking
at it on the prospective side is harder
to to distinguish between the two right
well people you know this is the the
problem of the bluntness of language
that comes from us all using a shared
glossary that we you know some of us use
things very precisely we're very
technical about it and we mean only what
it is that we intend to imbue into those
words and other people just sort of hear
it Loosely and so the idea of you know
is is that pharmaceutical safe right
well you know if you talk to me you're
talking to somebody who's spent an awful
lot of time thinking about how
Pharmaceuticals might be unsafe on the
basis that we have test animals that
don't tell you what it is that test
animals are supposed to tell you right
so you're getting a technical uh
response rather than a you know safety
harm what's the difference
[Music]
thank you